left must be sick and tired of all this
winning after striking out on Russia
collusion and accusing the president of
being racist some in the media are
trying to topple Trump by literally
cheering for a recession watch this I've
been saying for about two years that I
hope we have a recession a recession
would be very worth getting rid of
Donald Trump and these kind of policies
seeing that we have been in economic
expansion for the better part of ten
years it's about time we get a recession
so when the president says this is the
best economy ever it's not and if we did
face a recession it would be normal and
it would be okay Trump sitting back
against these mainstream media attacks
though I think the word recession is a
word that's inappropriate because it's
just a word that the the certain people
I'm going to be kind to certain people
and the media are trying to build up
because they'd love to see a recession
we're very far from a recession okay
Katie
so last two quarters you've had three
point one two point one growth you have
no very not to high gas prices you have
no bubbles and real estate or tech low
unemployment strong wages without saying
yield curve you think all this is coming
I only take a few business classes so I
won't throw the yield please curveball
at you Jesse but this is pretty gross
right because the very people who are
recession hurts are the same people that
the media and Democrats claim to stand
up for and they're struggling in a lot
of ways because Trump and his
administration has been able to take
away a lot of the arguments that
Democrats have been making on the
economy for years so wage increases for
example we're stagnant under Obama and
for a couple of years before that
they've gone up the middle class has
been bolstered the tax cut actually did
affect middle-class families more than
the rich as the Democrats are saying and
they're having a very hard time going
into an election where racism being
throwing them at the wall is not working
the economy is something people can
gauge no matter who's in office and say
are they working to make my life better
that's the argument Elizabeth Warren is
trying to make and it's the argument
that President Trump is trying to make
but for people to say that we need a
recession to get Trump out is disgusting
because it actually
hurts people's welfare it hurts their
families and it makes living really
difficult so I think they should be
ashamed of themselves for continuing to
push that having a recession is like
saying there's gonna be another sunset
tomorrow of course we always go into a
new recession but hoping for it for a
political gain is pretty gross yeah and
the rest of the country doesn't believe
that because consumer confidence is an
all-time high and retail sales and and
spending among consumers two-thirds of
the economy it's very very high right
now there's just a big disconnect one I
don't think it's a disconnect at all
look I think Wall Street is not the
media and so right now we've had a
rollercoaster market for the last month
or so especially the last week or so and
that's evidence of people who are in the
money-making business who think that we
are on shaky ground in terms of our
economic future I thought this was
Obama's economy it certainly has been in
terms of getting us what you see is pump
has tried very hard in terms of saying
oh well I cut regulation I cut taxes for
the rich Katie not for the most of that
tax cut went to the 1% but and you see
here's the other tail Jesse Donald Trump
who was he going after he's going after
the Fed Jerome Powell who's he going
after he says oh you know what the Fed
is a bigger threat to our economy than
China he says we need more tax because I
think he says well let's think about
cutting the payroll tax he sees that
there's trouble coming he wouldn't be
saying these things if he wasn't worried
so that anxiety tells you this is not
the media saying anything this is Wall
Street and this is Trump I don't think
the president seems worried at all I
think he just wants to juice and already
hot economy to compete with China and
the EU well in truth I don't think that
the media is as powerful with business
as some are making it out to be I think
businesses watch the markets they and
and there are things concerning overseas
not necessarily our country but
especially the Germany for example and
obviously the trade war is a little bit
of a concern so only fundamentals can
actually cause a recession the media
can't cause a recession but I agree she
a recession is not a good look for
anybody the Republicans need more for
messaging than just the media wants a
recession and I think that's that the
president talking about tax cuts goes
right back to where the Republicans are
very strong and even if Nancy Pelosi
will never allow a vote for tax cuts for
made politically that's why Republicans
should talk about it all the more and
the president the week before the
midterm elections in 2018 at a rally
said we have a big middle class tax cut
that has come in and he promised it and
then nobody ever talked about it again
and now they're starting to talk about
it and I think they're trying to see
what tools do we have in a payroll tax
cut doesn't help the rich know more
people who are actually working a tough
job maybe two or three jobs they're the
ones paying the most payroll time yeah
we had a payroll tax cut under Barack
Obama Greg yes we did and thanks for
bringing that up you're welcome for the
media the recession is like Beetlejuice
if you say it enough times maybe the
monster will appear I will I kind of
disagree with you Dana I know I know no
no no because and I think you will you
you and I both read a very important
book by Robert Chiellini called
influence we do know that a lot of the a
lot of the structures in our country are
psych psychologically influence the
media psychologically influences a lot
of things and our markets are affected
by optimism and fear and Trump is
benefited by an optimistic population
people are excited they want to invest
if you can mess with the optimism you
can mess with the markets if you can
instill fear if you can instill the idea
Amitabh media did this with the police
they created this idea that all police
were created brutality wherever they
went
doing it now with race everybody's a
racist so they could definitely
influence our culture I think they can
influence the economy and I do think
it's selfish because they're doing cuz
they just hate this guy I remember when
President Obama under President Obama
Osama bin Laden was killed that was a
very proud moment you know I didn't say
damn it I wish he hadn't gotten him
because I can't stand Obama I wish there
was some have been laden with so that's
kind of the same thing I want a bad
economy because I hate this guy that
hurts other people it's very selfish
and you should be ashamed of yourself
want Williams lawn is so rich he can
afford to ride out a recession guys made
of money over thank you